like cuz a lot of times they'll say like
I always see the church Community just
say get married young that's the
solution and and it's hard cuz like as a
Catholic I'm like I think that that's
better for most people or it would have
been if we didn't have a system that's
paying women to be terrible uh like I
I'll give you an example this guy he
dated he married a woman and she was so
into him she switched religions for him
so she went from I don't know if she's
Christian or Catholic or something she
became a Muslim for guy she okay okay
okay but I'm I'm saying so like this was
girl that like you know he he thinks is
going to be a good mother whatever and
she ends up um now he hasn't seen the
kid in 2 and 1 half years wow and the
kid hates him so you know they'll say
well what about your legacy how do you
have a legacy when the mother is talking
so much and it's funny cuz like the
girl that was here before it was
probably her mom talking about her
dad cuz usually when they I don't even
say this to like be be me I've just seen
the same family Dynamics so many times